Phönix
Vorort willkommen meine Damen und Herren
zu Phönix Vorort am 15 Oktober 2023 ein
sonntagmgen an dem wir wieder mit ihnen
in den Nahen Osten schauen wollen eine
Woche nach dem Terrorangriff der Hamas
auf Israel sind die Vorbereitungen für
die Gegenoffensive der Israelis im
Gazastreifen abgeschlossen dennch
verschiebt die Armee offenbar den Beginn
dieser Offensive so meldet es zumindest
die New York Times Grund seit das
schlechte Wetter seit Freitag ist die
Bevölkerung im Norden des gasastreifens
aufgerufen sich selbst zu evakuieren den
Norden zu verlassen international gibt
es ziemlich viel Kritik daran auch an
der Abriegelung des Gaza Strip geschätzt
eine Millionen Menschen sind betroffen
über 700.000 heißt es sind bereits das
sagen die Vereinten Nationen auf der
Flucht beide Seiten feuern weiter auf
die jeweils andere Raketen oder fliegen
Luftangriffe über die Lage der Geiseln
gibt es nach wie vor sehr sehr
unterschiedliche Angaben einzelne
Kommandoaktionen deuten aber da bereits
darauf hin dass die Bodenoffensive nicht
mehr weit entfernt ist und unterdessen
fliegt auch nun die deutsche Bundeswehr
deutsche Staatsbürger aus das ganze ist
in der Nacht geschehen hat begonnen und
wird über den Tag offenbar fortgesetzt
Notizen und Bilder aus Israel und
Gaza der Gaza Streifen steht vor dem
Kollaps hundertausende Menschen sind auf
der Flucht Mitarbeiter der ARD in Gaza
berichten dass alle Teile des schmalen
Küstenstreifens bombardiert werden
unterdessen geht der Beschuss der Hamas
auf israelische Städte weiter immer
wieder mussten die Menschen in den
grenzortschaften und in zentralisrael in
die Schutzräume die israelische Stadt
sterot in der 30 000 Menschen leben und
die nur 10 km vom Grenzzaun entfernt ist
wird nun komplett evakuiert der Konflikt
zwischen Israel und der Hamas dr immer
mehr zum Flächenbrand zu eskalieren
israelischen Medien zufolge soll der
Iran Israel über die Vereinten Nationen
eine Warnung geschickt haben sollte die
Bombardierung Gazas nicht beendet werden
wer des weitreichende Konsequenzen nach
sich ziehen der iranische Außenminister
Amira abdollahia sprach in Qatar nach
einem Treffen mit hamaschef Han von
einem gewaltigen Erdbeben das Israel
erwarte der israelische
sicherheitsberirater hanekbi machte
hingegen deutlich dass Israel seinen
eingeschlagenen Kurs fortsetzen werde es
werde nicht mehr verhandelt ziel sei es
die Hammers von der Macht zu entfernen
die USA haben inzwischen einen zweiten
Flugzeugträger in das östliche
Mittelmeer entsand es ist ein
unmissverständliches Zeichen an Israels
Feinde in telaviv bin ich nun verbunden
mit ARD Korrespondent philpp kunchner
Herr kunchner Grüße nach telaviv die
aktuelle Lage zunächst lassen Sie uns
die in den Blick nehmen was haben die
letzten Stunden
gebracht nun wenn wir auf die Nacht
blicken dann war es zumindest auf
israelischer Seite eine sehr sehr ruhige
Nacht es gab keine Raketenangriffe auf
israelisches Gebiet also auch hier in
Tel Aviv wo wir uns aufhalten da gab es
z.B auch keine Sirenen die uns dann in
den Bunker geschickt hätten die
Situation ist aber dennoch sehr sehr
angespannt weil man natürlich auch nicht
weiß ob Gefahr vom Norden vom südlichen
Libanon droht von hisbolla Milizen also
da ist die Situation weiter angespannt
und natürlich hat auch Israel weiter
Luftangriffe umgekehrt auf den Gaza
Streifen geflogen in der Nacht also auch
da geht das bombardm weiter nun gibt es
diese Berichte über die New York Times
zunächst die auf Berufung auf
Kommandeure der israelischen Armee und
Informanten sagt Verschiebung der
gazaoffensive welche Gründe werden dafür
ins Feld gefört was hören Sie vor
Ort nun dieser Bericht führt das Wetter
als Grund auf dass es sehr bewölkt ist
das könnte z.B bei Luft bei
Luftangriffen eine Rolle spielen aber
man muss ganz deutlich sagen wir wissen
nicht wann die Bodenoffensive hätte
starten sollen oder wann sie starten
sollen und wollen deswegen auch nicht
spekulieren und deswegen ist es auch
schwer zu sagen dass hier eine
Verschiebung stattgefunden hat also da
sind wir sehr sehr zurückhalten sehr
sehr vorsichtig natürlich gibt es diese
Anzeichen ein Militärsprecher von Israel
der z.B gesagt hat es werde Angriffe von
Seiten des Wassers geben auf aus der
Luft natürlich auch über den Landweg wo
es ja auch schon einzelne Nadelstiche
gab einzelne Truppen die in den
gaserastreifen rein sind aber dennoch
die Anzeichen dafür gibt es Zeitpunkte
oder Hinweise darauf die kennen wir
nicht das war das Wording der New York
Times das haben wir jetzt einfach aus
ihrer Perspektive weiter kommentiert sie
haben über die israelischen Städte und
eine relativ ruhige Nacht gesprochen
lassen Sie uns über die Zivilbevölkerung
im Gazastreifen sprechen was können Sie
von dort berichten wie ist deren
Situation nun es wurden ja rund eine
Million Menschen aufgefordert vom
nördlichen Bereich des gasastreifens in
den Süden zu gehen und die humanitäre
Situation ist ohnehin schon sehr sehr
angespannt dort am Montag hat als
Reaktion auf die Angriffe der Hamas auf
Israel Israel die Zufuhr von Strom und
Elektrizität und von Wasser zum
gaserstreifen gestoppt das hat schon die
Situation sehr erschwert und jetzt sind
weitere Menschen plötzlich obdachlos
mehr als 500.000 haben sich auf den Weg
gemacht in den südlichen Teil des
gaserstreifens da verschärft sich die
Lage es gibt kaum Wasser es gibt kaum
essen und hinzu kommt auch noch dass die
Hamas aufgefordert hat zum Teil dass die
Menschen im nördlichen Bereich des
gaserstreifens bleiben sollen sie sollen
als menschliches Schutzschild dienen
dort um natürlich auch Raketenangriffe
auf den nördlichen zu erschweren die
Hamas versteckt sich ja in Tunneln in
Tunnelsystemen und die sind häufig auch
unter zivilen Einrichtungen
untergebracht das soll abhalten davon
schwere Luftangriffe zu fliegen ja also
an vielen Stellen eine sehr komplizierte
Situation das mittlerweile größte
Fragezeichen wird gemacht an den Hamas
Geiseln am Zustand Aufenthaltsort was
hören
sie nun wir wissen dass das israelische
militärkontakt zu 126 Familien
aufgenommen hat also müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass eben mindestens 126
Geiseln nach wie vor im Gasastreifen in
der Gefangenschaft der Hamas sich
derzeit befinden über deren Zustand
wissen wir relativ wenig ob sie am Leben
sind ob sie getötet wurden auch das
wurde von der hamasia immer wieder
aufgebracht dass man einzelne Geiseln
hinrichten wolle da wissen wir sehr sehr
wenig aber ich habe gerade eben auch
schon angesprochen es gab ja einzelne
Truppenbewegungen schon rein in den
Gazastreifen und da wurden in der Nacht
auf den gestrigen Tag auch Leichen
vorgefunden man hat Leichen von gefangen
genommenen von Geiseln zurück nach
Israel gebracht soweit also die
Bestätigung
ähm Besuche in der Region gibt es einige
sagen wir mal einen gewissen
diplomatischen äh
Tourismus äh mit welchen Ergebnissen was
können sie bisher ablesen n man kann
insgesamt sagen dass es große
Solidaritätsbekundungen gab sei es von
Seiten der USA sei es von Deutschland
ein Thema war natürlich immer auch
wieder auf diese Geiseln zu sprechen zu
kommen das sind ja auch Staatsangehörige
aus Deutschland Staatsangehörige aus den
USA beispielsweise im gaserstreifen
derzeit gefangen also um deren
Freilassung ging es was könnne man tun
aber natürlich auch in wie weit kann
Israel unterstützt werden da gab es ja
z.B jetzt diese Information dass ein
weiterer Flugzeugträger der USA sich auf
dem Weg begeben hat in Richtung Küste um
dort ein starkes Signal auszusetzen was
auch den Libanon abschrecken soll bzw
die hisbolla Miliz und insgesamt lässt
sich aber zusammenfassen dass von
denjenigen die hier Besuche abgestattet
haben eine starke Solidaritätsbekundung
ausgeht also alles auch Vorkehrung dass
hier kein Regionalkonflikt und
regionaler Krieg entsteht ganz
herzlichen Dank für diese Einschätzung
und Hintergründe und Informationen von
Philip kunschner Korrespondent in Tel
Aviv ich danke ihnen
merci meine Damen und Herren also alles
ist bereit so zumindestens auch die
eigene Positionierung der israelischen
Armee aber ist es geht nicht los das ist
das was man faktisch feststellen kann
die New York Times hat daraus gemacht
dass die Gegenoffensive verschoben ist
ganz aktuell und live läuft ein Briefing
da gibt es mehrere am Tag der
israelischen Armee und wir wollen
reinhören in das was diesen in diesen
Minuten gesagt wird von dem aktuellen
Sprecher Daniel
hagari
Abschluss von Libanon her und wir haben
einen getot getöenden und es gibt auch
einige Probleme wir haben zurück mit
Feuer reagiert und wir
haben dieser Stelle wo daraus geschossen
wurde
vernichtet das tun wir die ganze Zeit
der Staat Libanon ist zuständig und
trägt die Verantwortung wenn aus dem
Libanon geschossen wird ich möchte ein
paar Hinweisen geben über den Norden was
dort passieren soll
wir haben gesagt dass dort am Norden
müssen wir ganz vorsichtig sein und
natürlich diejenige die in der Nähe der
Grenze sind kann man dort überhaupt
nicht mit Autos fahren oder zu Fuß gehen
ja das ist alles
Norden des Landes das heißt die gesamten
Ortschaften müssen die Leute die dort
wohnen müssen dort gerade geschützten
Räumen
bleiben und wir sehen sehr stark auch im
Norden
organisiert und vorbereitet auf alle
Überraschungen und wir machen auch jetzt
ich über Gazastreifen wir haben
viele Positionen attackiert aus denen
raketten gekommen sind und die Israelis
Streitkräfte hat auch heute abend stark
attackiert auch im
gaserreiben und wir haben ein bestimm
Kommandanten der hammas vernichtet der
zuständig war für die gesamte Operation
der Hamas der hat alles
organisiert und der ist persönlich
mitverwickelt und er wird nicht der
letzte sein die wir töten würden in der
letzten Stunde haben wir wiederum eine
Feuer aus den Gasa strereiben und wir
werden darauf auch eine Antwort geben
also unsere Schutz ist nicht hermetisch
es ist ganz wichtig dass im Süden müss
man genauso auch hören was hauptkartiert
Hinterland
sagt um Leben zu
schützen darüber hinaus machen wir
weiter und um mit den Zielen die wir uns
vorgestellt haben
zuüberwältigen und vor allem die
hamasbewegung und die hamasorganis zu
vernichten und das machen wir durch
intensive
Einsätze im gaserstreifen und auch
außerhalb die gaserstreifen wir haben
viele Infrastruktur von Terror
vernichtet und dann kamen viele
Terroristen ums
Leben und wir wer wir Schwächen dadurch
die Herrschaft der gesamten Hamas in
allen Ebenen
gleichzeitig tun wir etwas um uns zu
verteidigen das ist auf jeden Fall ein
Kriegsgebiet und in letzten Stunde haben
wir einen Terroristen gerade in diesem
Bereich vernichtet und wir kommen an
alle die dort
sind ich möchte jetzt über den
Gasastreifen sprechen wir versuchen die
Bevölkerung aus der gasstreifen zu
evakuieren die müssen nach Süden gehen
also 100tausenden sind schon auf der auf
der Weg nach Süden des Streifens Hamas
versucht natürlich dur diesen Prozess
zum Stoppen zu bringen weil dank weil
dadurch kann die Hamas die Bevölkung
nicht
herrschen und die brauchen die als
Schutzschild und deswegen will die Hamas
nicht dass sie nach Süden kommen sie
versuchen also ich wende jetzt gerade
direkt an den
gazaastreifen
Anwohner geh bitte alle jetzt Richtung
Süden des
Streifens und dort gibt es Bedingungen
die euch ermöglichen werden am Leben zu
bleiben und ich möchte über die Berichte
über die internationale
Berichte die gesagt worden ist dass die
IDF das Streitkräfte bestimmten Sachen
gemacht hat
und Zivilisten mit Absicht getüt hat das
ist eine
zynische Versuch uns zu beschuldigen
Sachen welche die Hamas gemacht
hat Hamas hat letztendlich ist noch
böser als dech also als isstaat und
versucht sogar seine
eigene Bevölkerung zu opfern für seine
eigene Ziele und deswegen manipuliert er
mit Lügen und falschen Geschichten und
dadurch wollen sie auch das israelische
Publikum entscheidungsträge und auch die
Welt beeinflussen ich hoffe ich erwte
Entschuldigung dass auch in den nächsten
Stunden wird diese Mühe der Hamas
fortgesetzt werden gleichzeitig schauen
wir drum herum auf dem gesamten Nahen
Osten die Israelis Streitkräfte blicken
überall und sind auf alles vorbereiten
unsere Bereitschaft ist hoch und wir
sind auch im Westjordanland ja und
Samaria sehr Star
gleichzeitig führen wir ein Gespräch mit
den Siedler um der Siedler
Führung und sage Ihnen wie sie sich zu
verhalten haben die Arme beherrscht die
gesamte
Szene
und einmal um 24 Stunden haben wir neue
Anweisungen von Hauptquartier
Hinterland und teilweise kann man z.B
jetzt direkt zurück in die Schule
gehen diese Anweisungen sind wichtig wir
müssen auf jeden Fall diese Anweisungen
folgen die können das Leben
retten daniel hagari war das der
Sprecher des israelischen Militärs der
Israeli defense forces in chaffenburg
erreichen wir heute morgen Professor
Thomas Jäger Politikwissenschaftler
Universität Köln grüße sie erstmal Herr
Professor Jäger und schön dass Sie sich
die Zeit nehmen am Sonntag morgen für
phöniix einen schönen guten Morgen Frau
Arland ja ja ähm beginnen wir sozusagen
bei der Zeitachse Herr Professor Jäger
wo stehen wir jetzt eine Woche nach dem
Hammers Terror am Beginn eines
konzentrierten Militäreinsatzes oder
doch vielleicht in der Gefahr eines
Flächenbrandes das ist eine offene Frage
und deswegen hat ja die bodenoperation
noch nicht begonnen weil eben noch nicht
entschieden ist in welcher Weise sie
durchgeführt wird inzwischen wird ja
seit einer Woche sehr massiv Gaza
bombardiert das heißt die
Verteidigungsmaßnahmen Israels sind
schon enorm und die Frage die sich jetzt
stellt ist wie weit gehen Sie weiter in
welcher Form wird die militärische
Infrastruktur wenn die
Produktionsstätten die Waffenlager der
Hamas zerstört in wie welcher Weise kann
das Führungspersonal identifiziert und
eliminiert werden das ist die Frage die
jetzt bei den israelischen Streitkräften
und bei der politischen Führung auf dem
Tisch liegt und das ist eingebunden in
eine intensive Diplomat Diplomatie die
ja seit einer Woche stattfindet die
sowohl mit militärischen Mitteln geführt
wird die Flugzeugträger sind ein
diplomatisches Instrument momentan das
abschrecken soll dass sich dieser Krieg
ausweitet aber eben auch die intensive
Reisetätigkeit von Außenminister Blinken
der in mehr en Staaten war ebenso wie
sein iranischer Kollege die jetzt
eruieren in welcher Weise welche
Maßnahmen Israels welche Wirkungen
entfalten und das ist eine große
Gemengelage die irgendwann dadurch
aufgelöst wird dass man in der
politischen Führung Israels eine
Entscheidung treffen wird bevor wir
gleich sozusagen auf diese beiden
diplomatisch Reisenden noch ein mal
etwas näher eingehen hochspannender
Punkt
vielleicht noch mal eines sie haben
selber die Verschiebung äh der Offensive
angesprochen Professor Jäger es gibt
offensichtliche Gründe es gibt diese
Gründe die sozusagen noch einmal
öffentlich kommuniziert werden aber die
Frage ist noch was passiert im
Hintergrund gab es doch einen
verstärkten Hintergrund äh Druck im
Hintergrund der Amerikaner auf die
Israelis doch die Zivilbevölkerung etwas
stärker in den Blick zu
nehmen also das hat Präsident Biden ja
öffentlich gemacht indem er gesagt hat
das ist eines der wichtigen Themen und
das hängt nicht nur äh mit den
humanitären Gründen zusammen wo es auch
darum geht momentan humanitäre Hilfe aus
Ägypten zu organisieren die dort
eingetroffen ist aber noch nicht nach
Gaza kommen kann weil man sich mit
Israel noch nicht darüber geeinigt hat
wie diese Lieferungen überprüft werden
sodass keine Waffenlieferung hier mit
hineinkommen sondern es ist auch die
Frage wie sich dieser Konflikt im
Informationsraum entwickelt denn nach
den komplexen Terroranschlägen die die
Hamas ausgeführt hat und die für große
Empörung im inform tionraum gesorgt
haben droht ja das ganze zu kippen in
dem Moment ind dem die Opfer in Gaza in
den Vordergrund treten und das könnte
wiederum dazu führen dass die regionale
Neuordnung die die Vereinigten Staaten
im Nahen und Mittleren Osten seit
einigen Jahren anstreben zum Stillstand
kommt und das ist etwas was verhindert
werden soll deswegen ist die Reise von
Außenminister blinken heute nach
Saudi-Arabien sicher eine der
wichtigsten Stationen weil man eben im
perspektivisch und über den Krieg hinaus
denkend nach einer politischen Lösung
suchen muss und da spielen Saudi-Arabien
Israel die Schlüsselrollen und wenn
Israel über den Auseinandersetzung im
Informationsraum politisch isoliert
würde weil sich kein arabischer Staat
mehr auf enge Beziehung mit dem Land
einlassen könnte wäre das weder im
israelischen Interesse noch im
amerikanischen
das ist ja durchaus eine sehr
beeindruckende reiserout die her blenken
da seit dem Donnerstag absolviert sie
haben es angesprochen Israel da war aber
auch Jordanien da war
Qatar und jetzt eben Saudi-Arabien und
gerade Saudi-Arabien ist ja mehr oder
weniger mit der springende Punkt es gab
gestern Meldungen dass Riad
möglicherweise diese Annäherungsversuche
mit Israel auf Eis legen wird wie
gefährlich wäre das für die weitere
Perspektive die sie ja gerade schon
beschrieben
haben ja es war so dass es enge
Annäherung schon gab zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und Israel die in der
Tradition steht der Abrahams Abkommen
die die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
bachrein Marokko und Sudan schon in eine
veränderte beziehungslage zu Israel
brachten aber Saudi-Arabien ist hierfür
der schlüsselstaat und es ist nicht
unbegründet anzunehmen dass der Angriff
der Hamas im in der iranischen Interesse
liegt genau diese Annäherung zu
unterbinden und das genau genau das das
Ziel war dass man erreichen wollte es
ist war zu erwarten und ist sehr
plausibel dass auch Saudi-Arabien in
dieser Phase nun eben dass die
Annäherung nicht weiter verfolgt wird
die Frage wird sein ist sie aufgegeben
auf welche Zeit muss man sie
zurückstellen und das hängt wieder damit
zusammen in welcher Weise Israel jetzt
auf dem Boden agiert und wie die
hisbolla sich dazu verhält denn von da
haben von Beginn an die Drohung dass
eine bodenoperation Israels gegen Gaza
den Kriegseintritt der hisbolla bedeuten
würde auch da wissen wir nicht ob das
eine abschreckungsmaßnahme ist ob die
wenigen Angriffe die die hebollah jetzt
täglich unternimmt einen
Ablenkungsmanöver sind ob Sie nur die
israelischen Streitkräfte binden sollen
ob sie Vorbereitung für etwas sind das
ist sind sehr viele unwegbarkeit mit
denen man hier zu tun hat und für die
politische Führung Israels ist das eine
hoch komplexe und schwierige Lage unter
solch großen Unsicherheiten entscheiden
zu müssen mhm vielen Dank für die erste
Runde über das aggieren Irans und auch
des iranischen Außenministers werden wir
gleich noch weiter sprechen zuvor nehmen
wir die Karte Diplomatie noch einmal in
die Hand danke Thomas Jäger für den
Moment
auf Reisen in der Region viele
Spitzenpolitiker einige Tage lang war
das z.B auch der amerikanische
Verteidigungsminister Austin es waren
auch europäische Spitzen in der
Regierung Frau von in Frau metzola und
die deutsche Außenministerin befindet
sich auch seit Freitag zunächst auf
einem solidaritätsbesuch in Israel und
dann ist sie weiter gereist nach Kairo
dort hat sie unter anderem den
türkischen Amtskollegen getroffen aber
auch den ägyptischen Amtskollegen danach
gab es sozusagen nicht in einem Raum
aber versetzt diese Statements wir
beginnen mit Annalena
berbock während ich gestern dort in
Israel war wir eigentlich schon auf dem
Weg zum Flughafen waren haben wir uns
entschieden dass wir kurzfristig nach
Kairo fliegen weil während meines
Aufenthaltes auch deutlich geworden ist
dass es eine Aufforderung gibt der
nördliche Gaser Gebiete zu räumen und
deswegen sind wir kurz entschlossen hier
nach Kairo
geflogen ich bin hier seit heute morgen
in Ciro um vor Ort Gespräche mit meinem
türkischen ausm Ministerkollegen der
ebenfalls vor Ort ist zu führen oder
geführt habe mit meinem ägyptischen
außenministerkollegen zu sprechen aber
gerade auch mit der Arabischen Liga mit
dem Generalsekretär der Arabischen
Liga dabei stand neben der Situation
hier in der Region neben der
Sicherheitslage in Israel neben der
Gefahr einer weiteren regionalen
Eskalation standen vor allen Dingen drei
sehr konkrete Themen im Mittelpunkt zum
ersten die Freilassung der von den
Hammers nach Gaza ver schleppten
deutschen zum zweiten die Ausreise von
deutschen aus Gaza und zum dritten die
humanitäre Situation aktuell in
Gaza wie gesagt ist mit Blick auf die
Situation der von den Hammers
verschleppten deutschen das gerade für
mich als deutscheer ausministerin ein
wesentliches Thema in diesen Tagen weil
es sich um deutsche Staatsangehörige
handelt und sind acht Fälle bekannt mit
Blick auf deutsche Staatsangehörige
darüber habe ich gestern intensiv mit
den Angehörigen gesprochen unsere
Botschaft vor Ort steht im ständigen
Kontakt mit den Angehörigen und auch
unser Krisenzentrum in Berlin angesichts
der so furchtbaren Situation für die
Familienangehörigen und noch mehr der
Verschleppten insbesondere Frauen und
Kinder stand dies auch im Mittelpunkt
meiner gesprä äche hier vor Ort weil wir
alles dafür tun alle Gesprächskanäle zu
nutzen um Informationen be zu bekommen
in Westen Händen die Geiseln sind und um
alles dafür zu tun dass diese
unschuldigen Menschen freigelassen
werden Hammers muss Frauen Kinder Männer
alte Menschen die in ihren Händen sind
unverzüglich freilassen es handelt sich
hier um unschuldige Menschen um
unschuldige Kinder und die frei lassung
ist ein Gebot der
Menschlichkeit das zweite akute zentrale
Gesprächsthema ist die humanitäre
Ausreise aus Gaza denn auch in Gaza gibt
es einige deutsche Staatsbürger die
allermeisten sind Doppelstaatler und
auch um deren Sicherheit kümmert sich
die deutsche Bundesregierung deswegen
bin ich unter anderem auch hier in Kairo
wir arbeiten mit Ägypten und Israel
intensiv daran Lösung für die baldige
Ausreise dieser deutschen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger über den Raffa Grenzübergang
nach nach Ägypten zu finden dieser
Grenzübergang zwischen Gaza und Ägypten
ist auch zentral dafür dass humanitäre
Güter nach Gaza hineinkommen
können das ist das dritte große Thema
dem ich mir hier in Ciro gewidmet habe
dass insbesondere unsere arabischen
Partner zentral bewegt die humanitäre
Situation in
Gaza Gaza mit Blick auf 2,1 Millionen
Menschen die dort auf engsten Raum leben
die Hälfte davon Kinder ist gerade jetzt
einer unglaublichen humanitären
Situation ausgesetzt von den 2,1
Millionen Menschen in Gasa wovon die
Hälfte ungefähr Kinder sind sind
zahlreiche auf internationale human
Hilfe
angewiesen auch deshalb bin ich gerade
nonstop mit den Vereinten Nationen und
unseren anderen Partnern darüber im
Gespräch wie wir jetzt humanitäre Güter
nach Gaza bekommen
können natürlich die Entwicklungen in
Gaza haben einen großen Teil unseres
Gespräches
erfasst es gibt eine gemeinsame
Vision die
dass wir arbeiten
damit wir die humanit
Aspekte
lösen es es ist
wichtig diesen Konflikt zu lösen und die
Regeln des humanitären
volkerrechtes und die
Achtung Zivilisten in keiner Weise
insier zu nehmen oder ihnen Gefahren
auszusetzen das ist eine bestehende
Richtlinie und wir verfolgen eine
Richtlinie die auf grundsetzen
ohnebelarbeit passiert wir werden
weiterhin
arbeiten die schlechte humanitäre Lage
zu thematisieren wirsen gemeinsam diese
Krise zu beenden indem wir
die Besatzung zu beenden und die
Gründung
palästinensiser ST an den Grenzen von
1967 mit ostjorusalim als Hauptstadt zu
lösen
sicherlich tragen
die Fortsetzung der besatung und die den
politischen Perspektiven zu Verschärfung
der Lage dort das zu
militärischen gefech
kommt das also die Statements aus Kairo
und das bringt uns noch einmal zu
Professor Thomas Jäger
Politikwissenschaftler Universität Köln
für eine kurze zweite Runde Herr
Professor Jäger verschiedene
diplomatische Kanäle sind angelaufen
beginnen wir ganz kurz bei der deutschen
Außenministerin bevor wir noch mal auf
Iran
gucken wenn man nach sehr viel chen in
der Region und seit mehr als 48 Stunden
unterwegs ist am Ende noch einmal
öffentlich die Freilassung von Geiseln
fordert dann hat man wenig bis gar
nichts erreicht oder wie würden sie das
interpretieren ja das ist so und das
geht nicht nur Frau berbock so das geht
auch ihrem amerikanischen Kollegen so
auch die amerikanischen Staatsbürger das
sollen 500 bis 600 sein die in Gaza sind
sind nicht freigekommen obwohl es
gestern hieß Ägypten würde sie über den
Grenzübergang lassen das ist eine ganz
schwierige Lage und zwar deshalb weil
die Geiseln für die Hamas einen
ungeheuren Wert haben und das ist
zynisch das zu sagen aber so ist die
Lage und es gibt momentan keinen Preis
den man anbieten könnte äh um um die
Menschen die dort sind herauszubekommen
der für Hamas wertvoller wäre als die
Geiseln ja Professor Jäger sie haben es
angesprochen vorhin zu den
diplomatischen Spitzenkräften neben
Anthony blink gehört der iranische
Außenminister der wie wir wissen im
Gespräch war mit dem hamasführer in
Qatar kann man das was die Iraner jetzt
in diesen Stunden machen irgendwie als
konstruktiv
bezeichnen ja das kommt drauf an für wen
für Hamas ist das sehr konstruktiv denn
hier geht es darum und das ist die
iranische Grundlinie zu sagen sobald
Hamas unter drruck kommt sobald es so
aussieht als würde diese Organisation
zerschlagen das Führungspersonal
eliminiert wird werden wir dafür sorgen
dass es eine zweite Front gibt und dann
kämen die Angriffe aus dem Libanon aus
der von der Hisbollah auf Israel
das ist der Moment den Iran mit dem Iran
droht wie ernst diese Drohung ist das
ist genau die Frage und die Vereinigten
Staaten reagieren darauf indem sie eben
zur Abschreckung die Flugzeugträger
verlegt haben und die Botschaft gesendet
haben es soll sich keiner wagen den
Konflikt zu erwarten
und da kommen dann unterschiedliche
Interessen ins Spiel
etwa das Interesse Russlands das ja eng
mit Iran verbunden ist und Russland hat
ein Interesse an der Ausweitung dieses
Krieges Russland möchte dass der Krieg
die Amerikaner im östlichen Mittelmeer
hält um von der Ukraine abzulenken um
dort Vorteile zu erzielen oder anderer
Staaten wie etwa Saudi-Arabiens das kein
Interesse an der Ausweitung des Krieges
hat
und das das werden wir in den nächsten
Tagen sehen wie hier diese komplexe
diplomatische Lage weiterhin auf den
Konflikt ein wirken wird ja hochspannend
alle die miteinander reden und auch die
nicht miteinander reden z.B Washington
und Teran aber das sind wirklich sehr
diffizile Gemengelagen ganz herzlichen
Dank dass Sie uns das heute morgen hier
erläutert haben Professor Thomas Jäger
Politikwissenschaftler Universität Köln
herzlichen Dank Ihnen ganz herzlichen
Dank Ihnen frauland meine Damen und
Herren das soll es auch gewesen sein für
den Moment bei Phönix vor Ort ich darf
Sie darauf hinweisen dass wir nach dem
Presseclub den wir ja traditionell 12
Uhr senden gegen 13 Uhr wieder mit einer
weiteren Ausgabe von Phönix Vorort
zurück sind dann etwas länger dann
wollen wir uns 60 Minuten Zeit nehmen um
die Dinge noch einmal genau und die
Hintergründe zu erörtern für jetzt würde
ich ihnen gerne empfehlen unser
dokumentationsprogramm was Ihnen noch
einmal ein paar andere Ansichten an
diesen schwierigen Stunden bietet z.B
aus Nicaragua gute Information bei
Phönix
[Musik]
د